all right let's go to our next caller oh
I don't know why don't we go to the 773
area code our next caller is from 773
hey question for you 773 could you hear
my call with the last person oh yes I
was actually hearing it on a minute
glitch like last word okay
no I don't you know sometimes it's hard
to tell the difference between a glitch
and a feature but it's certainly
something that's going on okay who's
this in Randolph yeah so hi David love
you're showing stuff yeah I'm I'm Conor
up in Chicago my name is also David
alright good so I just had a quick
question on so in Chicago there's a lot
of progressives running right for a
local level and state level and
everywhere right so on there there's on
the Thundercats right so what I was
thinking is I don't really care what
happened with Jake and all that because
they happen to long ago that I sort of
let that influence like me going against
them if I like their policy like I want
your opinion on that yeah listen so for
people who don't know what David here is
talking about we talked earlier in the
week about how Jen Cougar of The Young
Turks was pushed out resigned fired who
knows right you never know from justice
Democrats because of some sort of
unsavory sexist blog posts from around
the year 2000 there's no question that
listen it doesn't even your opinion of
genk shouldn't influence whether or not
you vote for candidates that are under
the umbrella of Justice Democrats your
opinion of Justice Democrats shouldn't
even influence whether you vote or not
for these candidates the the position of
the candidates is what should determine
who you support in elected office so
yeah I agree with you completely David
yeah also I've been reading a lot of
comments on Facebook and your videos and
other youtubers videos when they talk
about this issue and it seems to me like
people are pulling their money they're
not supporting you know just as
Democrats because they're letting their
emotional stories Jane cloud their
judgment and not realize this is much
bigger than that
if you pull your money out then it's
politicians need money right they need
money to run and a lot of it so if
anything this should not affect people's
choice but it does then it really does
piss me off but you can't read them much
about it yeah but people can also
support the candidates directly right if
they want to express displeasure stems I
mean they can just don't it to the
candidates all right David point taken
and and well made thank you I appreciate
the phone call